I feel the same way  [Music]  these dads are gonna take we're gonna  take it we're gonna turn we're gonna  take it's gonna be a very close contest  so I haven't done this in nine years I  have not changed a day for probably  seven years I miss it so much I don't  necessarily I'm ready  oh we're ready gosh come on years  yours is talking so nice to have a baby  that's not like peeing in your face  while you do this I feel like we did a  lot a time I got a time it feels like a  lot I really don't like myself right one  two five five six six typers five six  marvelous diapers ha ha ha ha I got four  and I think I tossed the baby that  that's just absolutely unacceptable  [Applause]  [Music]  you